i think we're going to have a
disagreement here i just feel it i can
tell by the look on your face
lebron james
lebron james did not win mvp
giannis did we all know that
and i wanted to see how how lebron
played see if there was any kind of
response based on his play on friday
there was no response based on his play
he actually said that he was pissed off
he was pissed off take a listen to this
um
pissed me off
that's my truly that's my true answer
um it pissed me off because um
out of 101 votes i got 16 first first
place votes
that's what pissed me off more than
anything
pissed him off he said hey are we
watching the game of basketball how
closely are we watching the game you
know i don't know he's throwing it out
there and
he said you know what is an mvp it keeps
changing all my years in the league
sometimes it's this sometimes it's that
uh and you got i could tell
you're shaking your head why you don't
agree with him
it's not i don't have to agree with them
i mean we know what they are doing do
you agree with them they get they get
they find stuff to get pissed off about
no i don't think you could agree whether
somebody has a right to be pissed off is
there a right to be pistol sure should
he have gotten the other stuff 39
i'm gonna tell you what pisses me off
here's what pisses me off it's how year
after year people act like they have
they they have their heart of
understanding that they lack
comprehension about what most valuable
player means there's a reason why it's a
fixed with a year there's a reason why
it is the 2019 2020 most valuable player
it is not most valuable player in
perpetuity it is not best player in the
world it is not player around whom you
would build a franchise around it is
clearly
who was the most valuable player that
year it changes hands
lebron's title lebron's position as the
throne that the king sits on
and has sat on for years and is not
relinquished has not renounced he has
not renounced his throne is that of best
player in the world that is not what the
award is the award is a regular season
award that recognizes the player who had
the best season we over complicate this
conversation every single year it's not
that complicated yeah okay maybe
honestly it could be complicated at the
highest peak you're making it in history
and defensive player of the year why is
it so complicated he should have gotten
that many first place votes lebron had a
phenomenal year was there a narrative
attached
i don't know yada's got better than he
did last year there's a there's a
narrative attached when everybody wins
mvp if that was the case right
he's right
i'm gonna say this last thing i'm gonna
say this last name broadcast to you last
by lebron's rationale and by the
rationality of the people who
think that the best player in the world
should get it or to play around whom you
build a franchise and all that kind of
stuff should get it every year then
there'll be three dudes that have gotten
mvp in our lifetime michael jordan
shaquille o'neal and lebron james and
that's it nobody else would have ever
gotten mvp in the last 40 years or 30
years whatever it's been by that
rationale it will never change there's
an annual regular season award go ahead
floyd's yours mike
mike
lebron is making a lot of sense when he
says no okay the pissed off think all
right fine go ahead and be pissed off
because you're lebron james and you have
10 assists a game and people are
treating you like oh that's just normal
but when he says it shifts every year
sometimes it's the best player on the
best team
sometimes it's this guy's turn to win it
sometimes it's something else yes he's
right
if you're saying it's not the best
player in the world
so why did kareem win six
uh
so
he those were his six best seasons
yeah the other okay so that's the point
if you're gonna say based on that year
you can't tell me i think it was uh
two out of three years
michael jordan was still in the league
carl malone won two
in michael jordan's league why right
why because that's because he he might
have had and aren't it eight he didn't
earn it okay all right so okay so cool
so let's just do away with the mvp award
all together let's just make it like
everybody just let's not do the best
player is and give and give it to them
every year regardless of what somebody
else does
let's define it better you know it is
true that sometimes as anthony davis
said
my best friend anthony davis love you
a.d he said
sometimes the award is given before the
season is even played
and sometimes sometimes there's
sometimes there's a storyline that
people
you know attach themselves so like going
into next year lebron will probably be
the front-runner thanks to him saying
that you know thanks to this
conversation he's laid to find work for
people to go into next year saying hey
we got we got to stop giving it to
people who are not clearly the best
players in the world especially if
lebron wins a championship this year
he'll be the leading candidate going
into next season